Freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
Video wir steigen gleich in ein ICE
fahren zinhalb Stunden in die eine
Richtung und zweinhalb Stunden wieder
zurück denn wir werden alles testen was
es im Board Bistro gibt also nicht lang
schnacken los geht's wir müssen nach
Stuttgart heute ne
11 die Jecken ja schon los ne weißt du
welches Gleis keine Ahnung Gleis 11 11
Gleis 11 Alter wie Kölsch will ein Zug
sein also laut Recherche gibt es
wirklich crazy viel Essen im ICE
ne
boardraurant so Freunde angekommen
boardrestaurant hoffentlich kriegen wir
auch einen
platzgen me
Hand alles klar danke bei euch auch
danke schön wir sitzen wir haben
Platz verdammte Scheiße m und hier ist
die Speisekarte so Freunde langsam aber
sicher sind wir angekommen und wir
werfen mal gemeinsam einen Blick in die
Speisekarte unser Ziel heute ist im
Prinzip alles zu bestellen ich habe
schon länger nicht mehr am Bord Bistro
gegessen und deshalb bin ich gespannt
was es aktuell so gibt früher war das
relativ überschaubar aber ich sehe hier
schon es gibt z.B besondere
Winterangebote Schweine Gulasch und
Spätzle mit lamsbreu edelhell ich glaub
das ist eher was für später kriegt man
so ein schönes Bierchen mit so einem
winterlichen Gulasch dann gibt es
ofenbrot kartoffelürsing Eintopf okay
okay ich glaube wir fangen einfach mal
beim Frühstück an also ich weiß nicht ob
das jeder auf dem Schirm hat dass man so
viel essen kann in so einem ICE wir
haben ein französisches Frühstück mit
Croissant Brötchen Butter Nutella Honig
Konfitüre ein herzhaftes Frühstück auch
mit Brötchen ein vegetarisches
käseomelett ein vegan porri mit
Blaubeere ein veganes Porridge apfelzimt
veganes toppinghenus cas kann man noch
oben drauf machen also ich glaube wir
bestellen die beiden porridges das
käseomelet und das französische
Frühstück let go es sieht real Talk
irgendwie viel zu krass aus also es hat
sich wirklich was getan habe ich das
Gefühl hier so in bardbistro also ich
wusste das wird cool heute aber ich
dachte wir hätten viel weniger zu essen
deshalb hoffe ich wir kriegen das auch
alles geschafft aber wie geil wir sitzen
jetzt hier machen uns gemütlich und
bestellen unser Frühstück die beiden
gerne dann ein käseomelett und einmal
das französische Frühstück ich würde
noch ein Cappuccino dazu nehmen glaubt
nicht dass wir das alles essen und wir
sind beim Frühstück also es gibt
wirklich so viel wird Challenge heute
auf jeden Fall und er meinte der macht
heute die ich braucht Dich heute es geht
nicht bin gespannt wie funktioniert denn
Currywurst pomes die haben ja da keine
Friteuse du kannst ja nicht wenn der Zug
wackelt eine Friteuse betreiben Gemüse
Curry Gemüse Bolognese ich glaub es wird
ein bisschen schwer heute wirklich alles
zu essen aber wir essen viel so viel sei
gesagt hab ihr habt hier ein Backofen
was noch wir haben zweimal Stimmer
backof einmal mikrole einal
Kaffeemaschine ganz moderne
Kaffeemaschine auch noch dazu richtige
Zapfanlage fürs Bier sind in Deutschland
ne das sind die Pommes das sind die
Pommes die probieren wir nachher auch
mal jawohl sehr gerne die Sachen hier in
der Karte sehen ja auch alle wunderschön
aus da bin ich auch sehr gespannt klar
man kommt nie an die Produktfotos ran
aber ob die so gut aussehen und dann
auch noch so gut schmecken da bin ich
mir auch nicht ganz sicher aber schauen
wir mal Danke Schön irgendwie nice ne
man hat so eine richtig schöne Tasse wir
sind jetzt gerade Business Class
geflogen ne und für die Business Class
zahlst du ja unendlich viel Geld ne wenn
du da fliegen willst da zahlst du be
einem Langstreckenflug immer vierstellig
hier hast du auch so dieses Premium
Reisegefühl so ein bisschen jetzt gucken
wir mal wie es Essen wird alles gerne
auf dem Tisch wir sortieren das gleich
danke sehr hör mal das sieht richtig gut
aus guck mal bitte den Anschnitt no an
sieht schon saftig aus ne das sieht
richtig gut aus vielen Dank danke sehr
wow leute das ist unsere Ausbeute fürs
Frühstück wir haben das Blau
dann haben wir das Apfel porrid ein
käseomelette eine kleine Brötchenauswahl
die auch Alter die sind warm und
knusprig ja der hat die frisch gebacken
das krasser alssinessass jetzt schon
crazy und hierzu kann man sich dann
immer noch zum Porridge so ein kleines
Topping bestellen wir können unsere
pordes hier einfach frisch toppen also
ohne Witz ich bin jetzt schon sehr
positiv überrascht ich meine wir essen
hier mit WMF Geschir das ist einfach
krank irgendwie hat hat das echt was was
besonderes und falls ger denkt dass
irendwie super positiv reden wir mussten
Tickets kaufen wir haben einzig und
alleine Drehgenehmigung eingeholt also
wir berichten 100% ehrlich
käseomlett lecker käsiges Omelett dieses
Brot ich glaub man kann es nicht sehen
aber es dampft sogar noch einf ein
frisches Brötchen dazu Aufbackbrötchen
klar aber diger Aufbackbrötchen ma ich
mir auch zu Hause richtig käsig fluffig
finde ich auch ehrlich gesagt besser als
das was wir im Flugzeug hatten könen wir
wirklich perfekt vergleichen apfelsin
Porridge wow mit einem schönen Topping
ich fr nicht wie die das machen auch so
ein ich glaub alles ist aufwärm Bro aber
Porridge jeder Bodybuilder weiß
Mikrowellen Porridge ist ein Ding l sich
super vorbereiten auch gib
ih das ist jetzt komisch das ist kalt
die anderen Sachen waren jetzt alle warm
und das Apfel zin pordge ist komplett
kalt also das erinnert mich so ein
bisschen an so ein so ein Milchreis
Milchreis okay sind da auch Apfelstücke
mit drin hab kleine einzelne Apfelstücke
hast du probier mal den Bums bin
gespannt schmeckt lecker so schmeckt von
ze finde ich wenn es warm wä wirklich Z
von Zeh ja das stimmt sehr lecker weiter
geht's mit dem blaubeär Porridge ich
persönlich liebe ja alles was mit
Blaubeeren zu tun hat und das hat
wirklich eine sehr sehr kräftige Farbe
probieren wir mal auch geil aber ich
glaube apfelzimt ist einfach unmatchted
ist einfach ungeschlagen wenn das a8inhb
ist das n sieben wenn wir schon allem
eine Note geben dem omelet ne ist halt
so wie so ein richtig durchgebratenes
omelet ne was so an der außenut schon so
richtig so leicht trocken ist das mögen
Leute aber auch ich find's auch nicht
schlecht für mich ist das sogar das
beste von den drei Sachen ach nein was
ich halt jetzt gerade übelst geil finde
ist wie schön und ausgewogen man hier
frühstücken kann das hätte ich wirklich
einfach nicht erwartet du kannst ja
alles essen wir haben hier noch ein
warmes Croissant Brötchen hier noch ein
Körnerbrötchen dazu einfach ein bisschen
Konfitüre ich glaube ich bin Fan davon
dass die so viel einkaufen von den
Sachen die die verwenden we es wä
niemals so gut wenn die alles
Eigenproduktion hätten ich bin gespannt
wie es schmeckt gut was willst du hier
mit frisch aufgebackten backbahen machen
die auch obviously nicht selber das ist
jetzt auch kein Croissant aus
irgendeiner französischen EP es schmeckt
aber schon krass ich hinterfrage mich
gerade wirklich selbst ne wir lassen uns
immer extra auf Sachen ein wenn wir
Videos machen ne dann ist bist du viel
begeisterungsfähiger für alles aber ich
finde das gerade so geil find das so
cool gerade ich denke mir so wieso sitzt
du nicht jedes mal wenn du irgendwo hin
musst hier und isst das einfach alles
wir blicken übelst schlecht auf Deutsche
Bahn alle alle haben abfack auf Deutsche
Bahn aber wenn du so aus dem Ausland
kommst hierher kommst und diese
experience hast geil du feierst das und
das krasse ist dass ich finde dass die
Preise auch wirklich FA sind wir haben
vier Gerichte ein französisches
Frühstück zwei porridges das käseornet
bestellt und insgesamt 31,60 € gezahlt
und dafür werden zwei Leute auf jeden
Fall satt wir aber auf jeden Fall nicht
deshalb bestellen wir uns was neues zu
essen es ist Zeit zu
essen so wir gehen jetzt in die Snacks
rein wir nehmen bitte einmal die
Currywurst Pommes dann das Schinken
käsebaguett und einmal den veganen
Flammenkuchen elsart das wird mit die
spannendste Kategorie auch wegen diesen
Pommes einfach ne man muss wirklich
sagen es gibt unfassbar viel veganes
Angebot auch also die porrides waren z.B
vegan beim Frühstück es gibt vegane
Flammenkuchen es gibt vegane Currywurst
gibt veganes chicken da muss man echt
sagen das ist ziemlich stabil also es
ist preiswert es gibt eine Vielfalt
schauen wir mal was uns erwartet jetzt
sind wir in der Snacks Kategorie
angekommen und ich bin wirklich gespannt
wie diese Currywurst schmeckt und vor
allem wie diese Pommes sind dann haben
wir ein veganen elsester Flammenkuchen
das ist Veganer Speck oben drauf und ein
Schinken käsebaguett ich probiere als
allererstes mal den Flammenkuchen wir
haben gerade beim Frühstück schon gesagt
bekommen ob das nicht zu viel ist für
uns wir sind jetzt gerade wir laufen
gerade erst warm los
geht's so viel besser als aussieht
knusprig geiler schmandgeschmack viel
besser als er aussieht h auch in drei
Bissen Weg sehr lecker Nummer eins ist
weg wir machen jetzt einen Test und zwar
ob diese Pommes hier knusprig sind ich
kann es mir beim besten Willen nicht
vorstellen aber ich nehme mal eine die
eigentlich knusprig sein müsste ne so
eine kleine ja so ein Hauch ein Hauch
von Knusprigkeit ist da okay es geht
eigentlich also ich find es überraschend
gut dafür dass es real aus der
Mikrowelle ist also auf einer
pommesskala ist das auf jeden Fall
untere untere Mitte würde ich sagen also
wenn so eine geile knusprig frittierte
dreimal frittierte Goldies Pommes oder
so eine Belgische Pommes eine zehn ist
ist das eine vier aber man ist es auch
in dem Zug probieren wir mal die curryb
let's
try ne ich habe das auf der Karte
gesehen und dachte mir boah wie krass
ist das jetzt gerade Currywurst Pommes
im Zug aber es war auch zu schön um wahr
zu sein ich finde die Currywurst nicht
so gut ich finde die Pommes nicht so gut
ich glaube da gibt's bessere Sachen die
man sich bestellen kann aber das hier
war mein absoluter Klassiker immer wenn
ich nach Berlin gefahren bin früher als
ich klein war das käschinkenbaguett es
sieht wirklich nicht so appetitlich aus
ne so mit diesen Schinken der so ein
bisschen in Mitleidenschaft gekommen ist
in diesem intensivbofen es war jedes mal
geil ich habe mich jedes Mal gefreut
wenn ich das geholt habe deshalb let's
try du hast einerseits so ein
Schmelzkäse aber du hast andererseits
Frischkäse Senfsoße in der Mitte und ich
merke dass auf jeden Fall ein guter
Faktor Nostalgie dabei ist dass ich das
so lecker finde ich feier es aber
einfach ist schon geil ne die drei
Gerichte haben zusammen wieder ich finde
nur 19,20 € gekostet die curryburst 9,50
€ ich finde da bisschen mit den anderen
Sachen besser beraten wir müssen jetzt
gleich umsteigen wieder zurückfahren und
dann geht's rein in die nächste
Kategorie g ne komm Bahnhöfe sind
mystische Orte du befindest Dich für
einen kurzen Zeitpunkt mit Personen
verschiedener Herkunft und verschiedener
Destinationen an einem Ort und euch
verbindet dass ihr ein Ziel habt aber
ihr werdet euch vielleicht nie wieder
sehen darüber muss ich jetzt erstmal
nachdenken sehr
gut es fühlt sich jetzt höchst schon so
ein bisschen heimisch an weil wir genau
den gleichen Platz wieder haben so wir
sind angekommen im neuen Zug und jetzt
wird es Zeit die Hauptgerichte zu
erkunden und Leute es gibt schon wieder
zehn verschiedene Hauptgerichte acht
Stück auf der festen Karte und zwei
Stück in der saisonalen Karte wir müssen
die Fossilie mit bodonese bestellen weil
das ist wieder so ein Ding es kann
eigentlich nicht richtig gut
funktionieren weil die Nudeln werden ja
auch nicht frisch gekocht deshalb bin
ich sehr gespannt wie die sind und was
ich gerne testen möchte aus dem
saisonalen Menü den Schweinegulasch mit
spetzel wir haben noch einiges zu testen
darf man sagen dass das alles jetzt
nicht so spektakulär aussieht die
Hauptgerichte werden glaube ich eine
kleine Herausforderung ich mische h
einmal ein bisschen unsere fossili mit
Bolognese durch ich meine dann muss man
schon sagen ich find ist auch ordentlich
Soße drauf und so sieht schon nicht
verkehrt aus ne hier sind wir bei 1220
hier sind wir bei 1550 mit einem
Bierchen noch mit dazu der Salat der
Nudelsalat 97 auch wieder vegan übrigens
ich GLB die besten geals findet man
nicht bei den Hauptgerichten probier
jetzt aber einfach mal die Nudel try es
schmeckt so bisschen nach babyglas zu
dieser Garpunkt von der Nudel davor
haben Italiener nachtsangst fehlt halt
von allem bisschen was ne Soße schmeckt
nicht so stark Nudel haben kein Biss ist
f von Zeeh wenn Pasta Poier eine Zeh ist
ist das eine fünf cheers das macht mir
jetzt aber auch Lust auf ein schönen
gullasch darauf bin ich gespannt we ich
glaub so Spätzle zum Warm machen
funktionieren viel besser als so normale
Nudeln warm zu machen funktionier
wirklich viel besser hab so ein bisschen
mehr Biss so dieses teigige knödelartige
und der Gulasch geht auch also wirklich
nicht verkehrt das schmeckt echt gut ich
finde es sieht nicht so gut aus ne aber
es schmeckt wirklich lecker wenn du dem
ganzen jetzt eine Note geben müsstest
würde ich ih glaube ich sogar auch eine
von Zeh geben somit die beste heute es
schmeckt auch wirklich winterlich kommen
wir jetzt zum versteckten Star des Tages
vielleicht hier ist der vegane
Nudelsalat wir probieren auf jeden Fall
mal machast so ein bisschen schön so wie
bei Antipasti so ein bisschen Paprika
mit drin und so sieht echt gut aus glaub
paer noch mit dabei probieren wir ich
glaube der ist sehr
würzig voll richtig gut ohne Witz ich
nudalat kalt schmeckt auch einfach immer
richtig gut der darf auch so richtig so
Kühlschrank kalt sein das ist auch so
ein Ding so da willst du nicht aufhören
zu essen das ist so ein schaufelgericht
so immer weiter schauel das ist auch
eine 8 von ze würde ich sagen eine gute
auch hier wen man satt werden will mit 9
der beste Deal keine Frage so wir haben
jetzt einmal die gesamte Speisekarte
durch wir haben vier verschiedene
Frühstücksvariationen getestet drei
verschiedene Snacks drei Hauptgerichte
und ich bin wirklich randvoll ich war
wirklich überrascht wie gut und wie viel
sei das Essensangebot hier in der Bahn
ist wir haben gerade noch mit dem
Personal hier gesprochen und der hat uns
erzählt dass das früher noch mal eine
Schippe krasser war weil da wurde noch
frisch gekocht hier drüben in der Küche
so klar ist alles jetzt aufgewärmt und
zusammengestellt aber ich find es
trotzdem qualitativ echt gut falls ihr
darauf Lust habt dass wir noch ein
bisschen mehr auch so die kulinarischen
Züge erkundigen weil da gibt es ja viele
wo man auch besonders gut essen kann
dann schreibt das mal in die Kommentare
weil ich glaube ich habe echt Lust
darauf jetzt haben wir aber etwas
bestellt was hier vor uns steht und zwar
ein
buttermandelkuchen dazu habe ich mir
esesso rausgelassen eric hat einen
schaumigen Cappuccino es ist einfach ein
Traum mir hat heute auf jeden Fall echt
viel Spaß bereit und die Zeit ist auch
wie im Flug vergangen wie im Zug die
Zeit vergangen also 5 Stunden waren wir
unterwegs fühlt sich an wie eine und
gleich sind wir wieder zurück in Köln
des würde ich sagen wenn euch das Video
gefallen hat lasst ein Kommentar da
schreibt wie gesagt ob ihr Bock habt
dass wir noch mehr Züge testen sollen
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal
wieder bis dahin ciao ciao